in the last hour it has been confirmed
that covert 19 deaths in the UK have
passed 10,000 let's get more now from
Sponge Bob undock in the newsroom for us
it is a grim milestone Laura what more
can you tell us about those figures it's
a grim and very sobering moment I think
in the outbreak were looking at the
figures throughout the four nations we
now know that 657 more people have now
died from coronavirus in England in
London a hundred and thirty more people
have died that takes a total number of
confirmed deaths in England to 9594
there have been 24 more deaths in
Scotland that takes the total to 566 in
Wales 18 more people have died bringing
the total there to 369 and in Northern
Ireland eleven more people have died in
total 118 dying from coronavirus there
where we have got have been hearing from
the Scottish Health Minister who did add
a word of caution when we look at some
of these figures particular obviously
referring to Scottish figures there and
that is perhaps the effect the bank
holiday might be having on some of these
figures because as we've seen over the
last few weeks after a weekend when you
come to looking that figures on the
Monday there does seem to be a slight
lag in terms of the figures so we're
still we're seeing a drop in the figures
after a weekend and that appears to be
the case after this long bank holiday
weekend we're seeing at the moment and
certainly in Scotland or while they have
increased the amount of time that you
can register deaths they allowed
operating on a seven-day-a-week system
there so including weekend's they do
believe that we should treat with
caution some of these figures because we
know that the true figures are likely to
be much much higher and that will
probably will be borne out in the coming
days after this Easter weekend let's
have a little listen to the Health
Minister of Scotland and hear what she
was saying little earlier today is of
course an Easter Sunday like no other we
have experienced I want to thank
everyone across the country for staying
at home I know this isn't easy but your
actions your sacrifices are making a
difference so I'm asking you to please
with it it is vital that we slow the
spread of this virus and save lives when
it comes to what these figures might be
telling us about the spread of the virus
we do know that if we're looking at
overall trends the things we start to
look for the number of positive cases
reported the number of people ending up
in hospital then of course there are
MERS of people who've died from the
virus as well and what we are starting
to see in the figures although this is
very very early days it's a perhaps
slight plateauing of certainly the
number of positive cases being reported
and the number of people who are ending
up in hospital as well but when we talk
about a figure of over 10,000 deaths in
the UK though now we have to remember
this is much more than a statistic this
is 10,000 individuals 10,000 people
whose death is leaving behind friends
family members and colleagues missing
them very much